i think um
i think typically
women i think typically women are um
more preyed on by men
um or at least in a woman's lifetime
and they would have experienced
harassment in comparison to men so it's
easier for people to believe a woman
whenever she whenever she
makes these claims because
just generally speaking or in at least
my personal experience majority if not
100 of the women i've
women i know have at least at some point
in their lifetime experience harassment
by males whereas none of the men i know
have experienced it which is why i
believe it's easier
to um to believe a woman without the
facts even though it's not right to do
so
yeah
what do you guys think
i mean like
it's like judging a book by its title
really you haven't read the whole story
to really understand what's going on so
just going off the back i feel like
maybe we need to actually
learn to assess things properly before
we jump to conclusions because you never
know that woman generally could be lying
on someone's name for her own benefit so
yeah it is a bit it was a bit toxic that
that situation so i'm just curious to
the girls have you ever had a girl that
you know tell you that she'd been
assaulted
oh yeah 100 100 yeah dude do you
question it or do you automatically
believe her i never question the victim
i try to not but i will ask questions
if she's comfortable answering those
questions
um
but i think it's important to at least
start off by believing the victim
because they need to be comfortable
enough to tell you yeah and there's a
lot of like emotion attached to it as
well it's not just like them you know
telling the story there's a lot of like
ptsd emotion and things that are going
with it
i've had to fight a person once
but yeah but i've seen that thing happen
like i've seen that yeah yeah yeah
it was um it was one of my friends and
stuff like that shot a
guy over i guess and
yeah one thing led to another he was a
bit there i heard something that i
shouldn't have heard i walked in and
this guy's doing my masolines next to
you know
busted his head through the window so
make sure you guys bring the mic to your
mouth if you're gonna talk just there's
some comments about it um what do you
think
so it's interesting though because we
say like
we can't just believe all women but we
kind of do as girls you know like if a
girl comes to you and says something
like that that's kind of our immediate
gut reaction
and it's tough because i feel like
celebrity situations kind of model real
life you know what i mean like like
they're kind of examples of what's going
on in like our real lives but like when
it hits the forefront that's when you
have an example of it
i think
i think that's because as women
we've experienced similar things so it's
hard not to believe someone coming out
and saying these things because it's
unfortunately so common
so yeah so me being
a victim of domestic abuse um
i feel like for me to tell someone was
very hard i wouldn't tell anybody so if
somebody comes up to you and actually
talks about it then i would actually
believe them because it's not just like
yeah a topic you just you know tell
anyone yeah so yeah
um
on
the question that you asked i think why
you would
um
believe the woman first is because
obviously if you see a man
saying that he's getting beat up by his
girlfriend that's
it's
it happens but it's rare like
men are seen as stronger than women
so it's like
when a man's
saying he's getting abused by his
girlfriend or and a girlfriend saying
you're more likely to believe the girl
because
men are seen to be bigger stronger it's
like it's
it's
unlikely that a girl is gonna beat up
their boyfriend but it does happen so
yeah that's why i think yeah women are
believed you know what's interesting
i've heard more men tell me like in
person my personal life that they've
been victims of domestic assault than
women
really yeah like because a lot of guys
don't report it because they don't feel
comfortable because you're getting beat
up by a girl
so is that also like another problem
it's like a good
guy
like you know i'm fine takes a whole new
meaning for the guy versus you know i
mean because when a girl says i'm fine
like you gotta go and you gotta make
sure that she's really fine because
she's never fine but like when when a
guy says it's like he's holding a
different meaning
yeah like she was just saying it was
hard for like you to come out and speak
about it
i think as a man it may be even be
harder because
um
like
people could laugh at you like if you're
a woman you get bit more sympathy i
think but if your mind is gonna be even
harder like
if you're going through that sort of
thing yeah you have to be quite quite
strong and brazilian yeah yeah it's
going to happen because because
generally speaking like if a man comes
out saying oh my wife be always like
most guys responses and even some of the
females i listen stop being a [ __ ] like
why why you being a [ __ ] you know what
i mean
yeah like you know what i mean like yo
you're the man of the house why are you
not why are you not telling her what you
know i mean it's just that's
it
with um amber head and johnny depp where
he secretly recorded her confessing to
assaulting him she was calling him a
[ __ ] yeah you know gross
yeah yeah
100 for your relationship to get into
that kind of stage where
a lot is going on like that so
do you think that if a girl hits a guy
he can hit her back
i don't think so i don't think equality
last time last i checked human wanted
equality so that's a very mm-hmm
i mean like
i mean
you could like pin her down
like yo yeah don't try it you can't you
know what i mean but there's other ways
around it don't need to now give her a
black eye or something yeah i feel like
you can do other i feel like things i
feel like um
a man shouldn't
just because of the the the potential
damage it could cause you know and he
could then go into a rage but he should
he should like he said pin her down or
you know stand grounds you know what i
mean yeah not to just take because
devil's advocate what happened to that
guy in miami when he didn't hit her back
the guy in miami with the only fans
model
oh the one has to go stop he died right
right because she stabbed him
what
i got did you not hear about
and you know what's interesting in court
like um
men get four times the sentencing for
the same crime oh wow yeah than women
so it's like even if they do get
convicted like girls aren't really sent
to jail over this stuff it's really not
taken like the same yeah why do you guys
think that is
i think
similar to what i said earlier like they
get more sympathy because they're seen
as more
fragile yeah like feminine you know
girls girls aren't seen as like
people who yeah like who are men can be
seen as evil aggressive like but then
when women are doing the same thing
it's
you it's unexpected so like it's not as
believable when it does happen
that's crazy i was going to say so like
you said that obviously like if uh if a
woman hits a man you really shouldn't
like you know him but like where would
you draw the lankas for example like
hitting is one thing yeah but like if
you see a woman like like you said like
the man that died right it's a woman's
coming at you with a knife would you
feel like that's a
valuable reason for you to actually take
you but that's nice
you've got a whole weapon like she's got
a whole weapon like that you're fighting
for your life at that point she's put
you in a position where you might have
to actually knock her out yeah
yeah i think that if she hits you you
should be able to hit her back
because i think that women would maybe
take it a little bit more seriously
before you hit a guy
like i just think girls like today they
have no consequence they can they can do
damn near anything there's like no
consequence
but a guy he gets sent to like j